تاهل امس منتخب امريكا لدور 16 في كاس
العالم بعد فوزه على ايران بهدف لا شيء
مباراه ومواجهه كانت منتظره وتكلمنا عنها
باستفاضه يعني امريكا وايران واقفين في
وجه بعض في الحقيقه وفي السياسه فلما
يلعبوا مع بعض اكيد هذا حدث مو بس رياضي
والفوز في عندك تيرين مو بس رياضي كمان
الامريكيين اللي يعني كره القدم مو من
اشهر اللعب عندهم طبيعي انبسطوا واحتفلوا
هللو كمان بالفوز لكن لما تشوف ايرانيين
في الشوارع بيحتفلوا بخساره منتخب بلادهم
هذا الشيء مو طبيعي ابدا بصراحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الايرانيين المحترفلين معتبرين انه
المنتخب هو منتخب النظام اللي هما ضده
ونفسهم يخلصوا منه واللي معيشهم في ظروف
يعني يطول الحديث عنها والي كمان طالعه
مظاهرات ضده ضد ممارساته في البلد وما
بتهدا هذه المظاهرات من سبتمبر المظاهرات
هذه على فكره كثير من اللاعبين نفسهم
بيدعموها بس يعني ما باليد حيله يعني
الجماعه لما غنوا النشيد الوطني في اول
مباراه اتهددوا وصاروا يغنوا من بعدها بس
للعلم مو اول مره ايران بتهدد رياضيين
عندها ولا شكلها طبعا هتكون اخر مره اصلا
يعني هذه طبيعتهم يعني على الناحيه
الثانيه في امريكا كان في احتياج يعني
كروي ومعنوي لهذا الفوز على منتخب ايران
وفي الوقت نفسه كانت بتبحث عن الانتقام
لخسارتها في مونديال 98 امام منتخب ايراني
ومن اكثر المقاطع مشاهده وتداول هو مقطع
ابلاغ بايظن بفوز منتخب بلاده واحتفاله
[موسيقى]
والنعم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جديد